our scripture of the day proverbs 25 28
without self-control a man without
self-control is like a city broken into
and left without walls
Harry Truman said in reading the lives
of great men I found that the first
victory they won was over themselves
self-discipline with all of them came
first there is no discipline that self
discipline folks that's the truth
I have trouble saving I have trouble
losing weight I have trouble dot dot
self-discipline self-control it's kind
of like you know I hear the Millennials
they say whether they adulting yeah
adulting growing up one definition of
maturity is learning to delay pleasure
you pay a price to win it means you're
grown up
whether you're 22 or 62 you pay a price
to win means you're grown up the first
battle is self-control personal finances
80% behavior it's only 20% of knowledge
the problem with my money is the guy I
shave with if I can get that guy to
behave he can be skinny and rich we know
what to do we just don't do it you
listen this show and you know what to do
you listen this show to hear other
people that know what to do but aren't
doing it or other people that know what
to do and did it and they're inspiring
how'd you do that self control self
discipline you should never
to someone you need Henry cloud talks
about that I love it little Johnny you
need to go clean up your room little
Johnny does not need to go clean up his
room or he would have already done it
but you need to create a circumstance in
which little Johnny suddenly discovers I
need to go clean up my room otherwise
mom's going to take away my freaking
life I'm going to be grounded so I need
to clean up my room I'm going to flunk
this test if I don't study you need to
study no I need a study that's when you
say that's self discipline not mom
discipline you cannot discipline be
disciplined too for other people you can
put them in situations where they wish
they were but you cannot be disciplined
for other people they have to grow up
they have to decide you have to decide I
have to decide when you decide that's
when your life changes see that's the
powerful thing as God gave you the right
to choose you can choose you don't like
the way things are going change just now
you just changed ready ready set go
change you're not stuck you're not stuck
just change is it gonna take a while
yeah is there gonna be some pain when
you change you bet but change change
well our family has always what you're
gonna live in your family curse change
well we're hillbillies we're Cajuns
we're Italians we always do what and
then you put some negative thing after
that and you label your ethnic group or
your heritage with that let this
negative thing we've all got tempers so
stop change we don't know how to save
money so learn change we don't know how
to be nice to our wives
so change you have the power
it's a power of choice the power of
choice is an amazing gift
decide that's what we admire when we
watch these debt-free screams or listen
to these debt-free screams that's what
we admire when we run into our friend we
ran into a friend this week who had lost
38 pounds since I've seen him what dude
where'd it all go I mean I was just like
I'm so proud of him proud of his success
what'd you do yes I just didn't eat as
much Oh dadgum insightful man Wow
where'd you come up with that formula oh
and then you say something stupid like I
wish I could do that yeah you could you
just decide it's change I like chocolate
cookies I know don't eat as many of them
change I don't like being broke change
work more spend less save more it's a
hard formula in it it's hard not because
of the formula not because the math is I
don't know if I could ever get out of
debt I don't understand math yeah you do
you understand math we're not dealing
with you know some graduate level
calculus formula here people this is the
second grade we're dealing with here
you learned addition and subtraction in
the second freaking grade you understand
the math don't tell me I'm good at math
you got out of the second grade okay
that's it it's not a chemistry formula
here it's the second grade don't spend
more than you have oh that's insightful
Ramsey you know I gotta tell you it get
you elected to Congress because nobody
up there he's got that figured out don't
spend more than you have and you will
have money left over to give and to say
and you will prosper when you give and
you save because you don't spend more
than you have well you don't know shut
up don't spend more than you have so
make more but don't spend more than you
have this is how you become a
millionaire this is how you change your
family tree this is how you change your
destiny how you change your life how you
have options in your life to drive a
nice car instead of a piece of crap this
is how you get to go on vacation on the
good cruise ship instead of the cheap
one don't spend more than you have don't
spend more than you have see the problem
is is we've we all have gotten so
prosperous in America that even stupid
people are prosperous we're so
prosperous that even undisciplined dolts
are prosperous we're so prosperous that
poor people are prosperous compared to
other countries and other other
civilizations and so average is
prosperous below average is prosperous
in our culture average is fifty-seven
thousand dollar a year income that's
average if you make $34,000 you're in
the top 1% of income earners in the
world you're a one percenter wealth
inequality whoo you need to give some
back because you make $34,000 a year
because of that we've just gotten lazy
and we've forgotten the ancient word
that will set you free
you have to learn the ancient word if
you want to be set free no one says it
anymore because it's politically
incorrect you're not allowed to tell
entitled people this word everyone's
entitled you cannot use this word
anymore you cannot use it for yourself
and you cannot use it on anyone else
it's very very unpopular I'll teach you
how to say it because it will cause you
to build
and it will change your life are you
ready you press your tongue towards the
roof of your mouth you make a kissing
motion with your lips and you blow air
past and release your tongue it sounds
like this no it's a word you're not
allowed to say anymore no it's a
complete sentence
daddy I want know we we we need a new
carton no you want dessert
no no will change your life but it's
abrasive and conflict based and visceral
and it'll freak your life out and people
will get mad at you no it's a wonderful
word we need to reinstate it in America
no that puts this our that I Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there is ultimately only one
way to financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the Prince of Peace
Christ Jesus